this is Sheppard civilians have been
evac special forces can take it from
here we're dropping you into a hot zone
get down there and engage the enemy the
cool thing about what we've done with
mass effect 3 and connect is that you
know we're using voice for the areas in
the game where you as a player would use
your voice if you were in that actual
situation James frag grenade examined
one of the really cool things about what
you can do in combat for example is you
know in many many games you're busy with
the controller you're actually your
hands are moving and you would like to
do something else you would like your
squad members to help you out but you
don't have any extra fingers but in Mass
Effect 3 you can actually say my name
you know liara take out this enemy James
switch to shotgun and you can actually
tell them these things and they'll do it
and once you're doing that you realize
that these characters feel like they
come alive you have more control over
the game and it actually really does
help the thing that actually made us
decide we wanted to integrate connect
was that you know first of all the
hardware and software that is part of
what we get as developers from connect
really kind of skips the research and
development process for us to where we
can literally plug in a function from
the game to your voice as the player you
know we also realized that because our
game uses conversation we wanted players
to actually be able to speak with
virtual characters in the game and speak
those conversations instead of speaking
through pressing buttons James follow me
James concussive shot one of the things
we actually asked ourselves was what are
the things that players yell at their TV
and let's let those things actually do
things in the game Mass Effect 3 comes
out on march six on the xbox 360 ps3 and
pc